so do you remember back being 12 when
you wrote or maybe even 11 writing that
first draft of whatever that script was
right or was it a young authors writing
contest I don't know if it was a book or
what it was but do you remember back the
encouragement you got and there are
things that you're trying to mimic oh
maybe slightly going different way well
I mean you know my mom was you know she
was she was a working mom so you know
she wasn't you know she actually
traveled a lot so she was out of the
country a lot for her her work I think I
was very introverted you know I mean I'm
a lot of people like they know I'm a
very talkative and extroverted person
but there's also a part of me that was
always very introverted and you know I
would always kind of you know keep
myself to myself and do my stuff but I
know my mom was always very proud of you
know my artwork and the paintings and
the different stuff that I would do and
you know even now she you know hangs
hang stuff up one thing that my mom did
that I just thought was amazing was in
her house she had an artist come in and
they custom painted the entire house and
what she did is they painted what looked
like a fake bookcase so from afar in the
hallway it looks like a real bookshelf
with all these books and then you get up
close and you see oh wow this is it's a
painting and the interesting thing was
that in this series of of books the
spines that you can see she put my
stories she put my name and so yeah I
don't think I ever told her that that
you know how how profound that was to me
when I came into her house and when I
was walking home and I walked up to it
and I was like oh my god that's the
first screenplay I ever wrote and she
you know had the artist paint this you
know there's the first story it you know
so I mean stuff like that encouragement
like that sometimes I think means so
much more than just words
you know because you can't really can't
really describe you know how that feels
hopefully I can do something a gesture
like that for my own children one day
you